the voter intimidation is starting my
friends today's example is actually
an in-uniform police officer doing it
this took place in miami florida a
police officer
in uniform with a trump mask that says
trump no more bs walking around a
polling place
the officer is daniel ubeda
wearing a trump 2020 mask inside
a polling place at miami's government
center
attorney steve simonides who is also
chairman of the miami-dade democratic
party says quote
he may have been going to vote but he
was in full uniform
with the mask and a gun that's
voter intimidation and indeed it is
illegal
in the state of florida florida's 2020
statutes 104.32
referring to political activities of
state county and municipal
officers and employees says that no
officer of the state or any county or
municipality
can use their authority to influence an
election or to influence a vote period
and importantly that quote no employees
of the state
can participate in any political
campaign while on duty
if you violate it it's actually a
misdemeanor in the first degree
miami police immediately alerted to it
by people who saw this they tweeted
about it saying quote
we are aware of the photograph being
circulated of a miami police officer
wearing a political mask
in uniform this behavior is unacceptable
a violation of department policy and is
being addressed
immediately now of course there's a
bigger issue
this is an officer who broke the law he
shouldn't be working in law enforcement
period but we have no national database
of bad actor police officers we have no
such requirements we likely won't
anytime
soon as i mentioned months ago when the
george floyd protest started in the
context of the police reforms i would
like to see
a national bad actors database something
that would be brutally
fought to the death by police unions and
more than likely
we will get a sort of meaningless slap
on the wrist coming for this officer
don't worry he won't do it again at
least not for
four more years big consequences and in
all
seriousness someone sworn to uphold the
law
breaking the law while in uniform
a police department is as good as its
worst
officer and this is an individual daniel
eubaida
who may end up with a couple of weeks of
paid administrative leave while they
investigate what happened does anybody
think that's going to teach this guy a
lesson
but as i've said before keep me posted
on this stuff if you come across it i
got an email yesterday
i don't want to say too much because i
want to look at it myself but i got an
email yesterday
not about intimidation well actually it
sort of is
it's intimidation by text message okay
i'm asking for more information and i'm
going back and forth with the viewer to
really
uh vet the story but i may have that for
you
tomorrow or the next day but if you see
intimidation
uh if you get intimidatory emails if you
see intimidation at polling places
let me know um video is of course
ideal if you can safely and legally
record it if you can't
let me know what happened but the the
reports are starting to come in and i
can only
imagine because listen they've said
right trump said
go and monitor polling places uh they've
said
we are going to try to have uh
law enforcement of possibly federal
military uh at polling places
they've mentioned everything in passing
at some point and who knows what they're
actually going to try to do
um so help help me get the word out if
indeed you are seeing that
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars just for
using their free service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your
real card number stays completely
private
and you do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month
you can set spending limits freeze them
delete them whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman